[Music]
one of the most exciting things in the
world of AI and health is being able to
digitize the state of mind that is be
able to use different metrics to be able
to say this person is depressed or this
person is you know really happy and
doing well and so one of the really
great examples of this actually was
through Instagram where they actually
had a huge number of images and they
could diagnose depression based on the
types of images and the filter that was
used by the person posting but it's
actually really exploding because it
turns out that our speech how fast we
talk in our tone animation our activity
our breathing pattern if we sigh a lot
all these things can be easily
quantified passively they go in to this
algorithm and then comes out of it is
where is this person state of mind and
how can we get it boosted up because
that's really the issue are the
medications if persons using them is
that not even working now in addition to
that which is a shocking part of the
story is that when when a person is
asked to disclose their innermost
secrets they're more apt to do that with
an avatar than another human being the
idea that you would have this avatar
that you selected to be your coach that
was monitoring your your metrics and
giving you feedback and also that you
could confide in it's really alluring
and we're starting to see that I mean it
already is starting to blossom in China
for example it wouldn't be at all
surprising we start to see that in the
US and the near Turner so when you take
this ability to digitize a state of mind
and also have support through an avatar
this could turn out to be a really great
way to deal with the problem we have
today which is a lack of mental health
professionals with a very you know
extensive burden of depression and other
men
health conditions
[Music]
you